ادانت القمع الذي يفرضه النظام الايراني
على المحتجين تتولى على الصعيد الدولي
منظمه الامم المتحده نددت بما تقوم به
طهران في حق المتظاهرين مطالبه اياها
باقرار تعليق فوري لعقوبه الاعدام فعدد
الوفيات المتزايد جرار التظاهرات ومن
بينها وفاه طفلين في نهايه الاسبوع وتشديد
رد قوات الامن يشران الى ان الوضع خارج في
البلد يقول المفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان
المسؤول الاممي ذاته حتى طهرا على تلبيه
مطالب الشعب في المساواه والكرامه والحقوق
بدلا من استخدام القوه غير الضروريه وغير
المتكافئه لقمع الاحتجاجات وفق تعبيره من
بروكسل ايضا دعوه من اللجنه البلجيكيه
للبرلمانيين من اجل ايران ديمقراطيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي والدول الاعضاء في اداره
ما وصفته بقتل المتظاهرين في ايران واتخاذ
اجراءات تقليديه عاجله وفرض عقوبات لوقف
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
هذا في وقت اتهمت مجموعات حقوقيه قوات
الامن الايرانيه باستخدام الرصاص الحي
واسلحه مختلفه لقمع المحتجين في المناطق
التي يقطنها الاكراد
هذا وحذر نشطاء من ان ايران تخطط لجعل
عقوبه الاعدام اداه لقمع الحركه
الاحتجاجيه عبر اشاعه مناخ من الخوف بلال
الوجداني العربيه